immer nur meckern meckern meckern alle sind
unzufrieden mit unseren Politikern mit der
großen Koalition ich muss einfach mal ganz ehrlich
sagen ich bekenne mich dazu ich finde Merkel geil
ich bin ein ich bin ein Riesenwerk Merkel es
ist nichts Inhaltliches muss ich dazu sagen
es ist rein sexuell bedingt bei mir wirklich
ich finde einfach macht machen Menschen so
sexy man ja einfach so abperlen sensationell
Pressekonferenz souveräne Statement von ihr
und anschließend wird immer so direkt ab mit
Pressesprecher Referenten und dann sagt immer
sofort irgendwas zu denen das hört man dann
aber nicht und das ist richtig geil wenn du
sagst ja das ist unsere Stellungnahme zur
Krise und dann stampft sie immer so weg
und dann stelle ich bevor wir zum Seibert
sagt nach Steffen ohne Playstation zocken
wenn ich das sehe Leute da habe ich ein
kleines bonjour Tröpfchen in der Hose muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen das ist jetzt auch sie
in der krim-krise bei Putin Putin finde ich
auch geil ich bin ein riesen Putin Fan ich
finde der liegt ein Hammer ja hin oder mal
eben die Ukraine einen verleiben sich mit
einem halben Westen Anliegen vorher noch
Olympische Winterspiele im subtropischen Gebiet
außer erwischt nee ich sage immer was machen
Männer nicht alles um von der eigenen
Homosexualität abzulegen oder [Applaus]
das ist doch [__] oder nicht putin ist doch
schwul das denke ich mir noch nicht aus oder
die Signale sind noch da eindeutig oder andauernd
diese halbnacken selfies beim Angeln beim Jagen
auf auf irgendwelchen schimmeln durch die Tundra
Reiten mit mit Pfeil und Bogen auf irgendwelche
Armenia schießen er sagt immer es ist Damwild aber
sind Armenia das sind einfach mal [__] hallo
ist eine schwule Gefahr weil das Unterdrücken
der Macht Judo gibt es irgendein Sport wo sich
Männer mehr an krabbeln als beim Judo ja gut beim
Fußball okay meinetwegen aber ganz ehrlich wenn
Putin nicht schwul ist dass ich mir die Rosette
bleachen das ist mal ich weiß drei seit Jesus
Spruch so unangemessen wie ein Kinderballett auf
der SPD entlassungsparty von edathi oder oder wie
als Frau beim One-Night-Stand zu sagen hoch vom
Geruch her die mir größer vorgestellt aber ich
sorry
es tut mir leid ich habe in der letzten Zeit ich
habe so ein Politik sexualisierungs Tourette ja
immer wenn ich darüber reden Politiker machen
und und Obama finde ich auch geil muss ich bin
auch ein riesen Obama wenn ich mich entscheiden
müsste Putin Obama oh das wird ganz schwer aber
irgendwie Obama hat die geilere MILF als Frau das
ist schon ganz schwer zu unterscheiden Obama ist
auch ständig im Einsatz und die Krisen dieser Welt
zu lösen wer wenn ich der Friedensnobelpreisträger
sein Leben soll ja jetzt verfilmt werden
mit Tom Cruise also Barmer bin ich sehr
sehr gespannt drauf böse Zunge Obama hätte den
Friedensnobelpreis nur gewonnen weil er nicht
george war aber ich finde es vollkommen konsequent
dass er den gewonnen hat Alfred Nobel ja er findet
war einer der größten Waffenproduzenten seiner
Zeit dachte sich oh das ist nicht so gut für mein
Image Friedenspreis deswegen er sah seine Waffen
als Beitrag für ein Frieden durch Abschreckung an
ist wirklich ein Pazifisten natürlich runter wie
TNT also im Prinzip hat er diesen Preis nur aus
Image Gründen gestiftet Obama hat ihn eigentlich
nur aus image gewonnen das ist vollkommen
konsequent und deswegen wäre es auch vollkommen
konsequent wenn als nächster der Sexiest Man Alive
diesen Port gewinnen würde Kim Jong-un oder so ein
bisschen Glamour in die Preisverleihung bringen
mit dem Gewinn dem Lächeln vor allen Dingen wer
der Preisträger noch mal wieder konsequent immer
der lebt es uns doch vor was Konsequenz ist der
war genervt von seinem Onkel und Bart hat er den
einfach mal überhaupt Haufen geballert das ist
doch ein Vorbild für uns alle oder ganz ehrlich
wie oft sitzen wir Weihnachten zwischen der
buckligen Verwandtschaft und denken uns also
Onkel Bären die noch ein Wort und gut kann man
nicht machen sind ja auch immer Kinder im Spiel
übrigens Kim Jong-un ist in der Schweiz zur Schule
gegangen und viele Brösel ist jetzt in die Schweiz
zum Weltwirtschaftsforum gegangen ne Sache noch
einmal die lassen da kein rein also wird mich
nicht wundern wenn demnächst viele Grüße als neuer
Onkel von Kim Jong-un vorgestellt werden aber
zurück zum Thema welches Thema un Obama Vorbilder
viele fragen sich in unserem Land Mensch was ist
eigentlich mit unseren moralischen Instanzen los
höhnes schwarzer ADAC an wen können wir überhaupt
noch glauben und das sage ich ganz klar an alle
glaubte sucht euch was aus woran ihr glauben die
kommen auch alle wieder zurück aber ihr müsst
Glauben hält und zusammen glauben ist auch viel
wichtiger als Wissen zu viel Wissen ist auch eine
Behinderung wenn man zu viel weiß gerade wenn man
irgendwann sechs Wochen auf dem Flughafen
das ist überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht gut
wobei
ganz ehrlich Snowden der Typ auch
vollkommen überbewertet alles was
der weiß hat er auch noch aus dem Internet aber
zu viel Wissen mit blockiert euch im Leben
wenn man zu viel weiß kommt man überhaupt
nicht voran vielleicht da einfach mal
drei Beispiele geben gerne auch nur
eins hey wir haben doch alle schon mal die
AGBs von Apple oder Microsoft durchgelesen
nee aber haben sie alle schon mal akzeptiert
das immer gar nicht so genau wissen weil ich
leide sehr unter meinem Wissen muss ich dazu
sagen weil ich so viel weiß ich komme in der
letzten Zeit immer zu spät muss ich kurz erklären
ich bin heute hier am späten Nachmittag in Berlin
aus meiner Wohnung raus zieh die Tür zu schließen
ab auf dem Weg nach unten frage ich mich sowas
wirklich abgeschlossen Automatismus verzogen
mein verzieht man kann sich daran erinnern
jetzt habe ich Idiot mir wissen drauf gezogen habe
Anfang des Jahres gelesen dass wenn man sich dran
erinnert und deutlich ja und immer wenn ich
gemacht habe wusste ich habe abgeschlossen
aber nach ein paar Mal ist das so ein Automatismus
geworden das heißt ich gehe raus wie es ab macht
geh weg und frag mich sag mal wirklich gemacht das
abgeschlossen ja das heißt irgendwann irgendwas
irgendwann habe ich angefangen
ich gehe raus hier die Tür zu
machen mach mal ein zwei drei ja und
wenn es hier so ein bisschen gemacht
Mach 1 2 3 und dann spring immer einmal so in
die runden aber aber nach drei viermal war das
in die Runde springen so viele mittlerweile
ist eine ganze Zeremonie draus geworden also
ich zu Hause los ich gehe raus ich ziehe die
Tür zu ich sie ab ich mache ich mach 1 2 3
und spricht immer einmal so in die Runde und
dann gehe ich immer so im Hühner Gang Weg so
erst wenn mich jemand komisch anguckt
dann weiß ich aber abgeschlossen
ZDF hat einen Namen Qualität
also ZDF heißt ZDF und da ist Qualität und wenn
sie ZDF oder 3sat ist auch
also öffentlich-rechtlich
abonnieren